le départ de feu ne fait aucun mystère
c'est sur cette lucarne suite à une
soudure que le bois s'est échauffé
attisés par le vent des flammes ont
alors jailli et léché les poutres du 15e
siècle les ouvriers sont très vite
intervenus ce qui a permis d'éviter le
pire seulement 30 mètres carrés
endommagée sur les 2300 que compte cette
toiture et une charpente encore scène
pas question pour autant de risques et
une nouvelle tuile les soudures sont
suspendus jusqu'à nouvel ordre
on a deux pistes soient les lucarnes
sont déposés donc pour restauration
qu'on peut le voir et on profitera leur
séjour aux ateliers pour préparer au
maximum les plombs effectué les soudures
l environnement qui ne craint rien
l'autre piste c'est un peu la technique
des pompiers qui étaient claires sur la
caméra thermique qui permettra de revoir
après ouvrage c'est effectivement le
bois en surchauffe derrière le toit en
question chapeaute la magnifique salle
des pôvres malgré quelques infiltrations
d'eau dans un coin de la pièce forte
heureusement ni le lieu ni le mobilier
n'ont souffert
c'est le deuxième sinistre que provoque
le chantier déjà en avril dernier un feu
d'origine chimique était survenu sans
faire de dégâts là encore l'hôtel dieu
semble donc passé entre les gouttes du
plus grand risque que courent un
monument historique lors de sa
restauration
le risque incendie le personnel ici de
surveillance
le été sensibilisés à cette crainte est
donc veille tout particulièrement sur ce
chantier est amené à faire des rendent
régulièrement tous les jours donc il a
déjà eu à intervenir malheureusement
mais il l'a fait à bon escient et c'est
tant mieux
donc c'est vrai que c'est quelque chose
dont on a pour ça que le chantier se
termine
l'équipe du musée tremblera jusqu'à
l'été 2009 date prévue pour la fin du
chantier
en attendant toutes les précautions et
toutes les protections sont bonnes à
four